有观众看你直播打个招部能让直播心更热闹
不小那么热闹
这就是和老伙里面聊天这个地方
来了好我把那个什么东西掉了
我倒点水
完了好
我反映我什么东西掉了
但是我又不知道是什么
这个怎么办
钱掉了
没事
我钱掉不了无所谓
钱掉了黑灾症
所以钱掉的不是最重要的事
好一个差别算一算
我把草莉倒了钱
真好
今天这个什么情况呢
我带个华有找班
我找个啥
我找个
呃
什么
很好
最近更新的比较多
所以我的不知道上一周我讲到哪
我也不知道我上一周讲什么了
真的
我的不知道今天我最近我都讲什么了
我都忘了
我看看哪些老伙就好
黄镜
老伙镜
里撒
聊天
好
是这样
我也忘了我上周讲的
所以咱们聊到哪算哪
聊到什么地方算什么地方
主要讲的超多去东西
好 下次
最近这个
最近的这个计划特别快
然后呢
所以就有的时候会切换的比较多
反应不过来
好
去公公不知道我对去公不了解
今天讲什么
今天就是跟大家聊呗
我当下对一些事情的理解
跟简单的
还是关于这么思考
怎么写作
怎么把学的东西用出来
还是和自学应用有关
对 可以叫算吧
叫我的人生算吧
基础片
叫我的人生算法制几乎片
基本记呀 基本记很容易
基本是最容易的事
可以讲
可以聊
不了个
我觉得很没意思
说实话我现在觉得聊不得很没意思
那就像前就放在那儿
你就拿着玩事了
有些钱呢
你就可以拿
有些钱呢你就不能拿
你怎么知道哪些钱可以拿呢
你看明白了就拿贝
他明白就不要碰
所以他你问我说
你讲讲那个公司
那就说明是不明白吗
你不明白不能干嘛呢
对吧
对 今天可能会讲到一些联结
我觉得会讲到联结
会讲到一些好的东西
当机密器不要去去重点
我以后给大家讲一下
我怎么去机密机吧
我是怎么机密机的
我是怎么看书的
我是怎么学习的
这个还是很有意思的
我现在越来越觉得
这个
抖音这个什么地方呢
我也不是什么知识主播
什么是流量呢
啥玩人啊
跟我还没关系
我还要这么可能时间跟他们
特地跟我没关系
我觉得这个东西很好很棒
就是当于不是把眼光放的流量上
放在什么带过上
的时候你会发现
你说实实在在的进步
我觉得我的这个我的使我眼
才叫了交个朋友
我觉得在那个纯粹肚上
我的使不击眼才能称之为交个朋友
老婆就来了
所以拿好天宁园园园的
刚才还了拿了
哪个月呢
我现在能拿的出来的学历是
叫现在叫什么
叫闪戏
体路工程学院
好像是现在叫闪戏的工程学院了
以前不是以前叫围团体路工程学校
现在升级了
变成大转了很像是
这个状态真好
就是我最近的状态特别好
新书什么时候发生又延尺了
又延尺了
征取4月份的
征取4月份
原本是要准备到年钱的
然后感谢新人生
然后最近的整理整理整理整理的突然绝的不合适
然后我们和出了公司也商量了一下
推识
再推识
后面会不会再推识我不知道
我可能会
估计4月份
4月份能出来
我不是闪戏人
但是我在闪戏上的学
不是好多小伙伴会关注你呀
是你是哪个学校呢
对了
你要是北大侵划的
我就听一听
对吧
你又不是什么知名院校的
那我就离开了
讲一天不有一个方面
我给大家讲学习方法的时候
我下面很能说
就你以色
讲了半天学习
就搞了个中传逼
我说是学弟弟呀
水平差呀
所以你赶快取官吧
对吧
我最初创月的时候
三个人
对
然后后来就几个人
慢慢多了
大学生一万块钱
鲜钱怎么办
你是大学生是吗
那
大学生一万块钱鲜钱怎么办
我建议你就可以分批的
去买指数百一方面
另外一方面干嘛了
学习
如果你你会学习方法的话
就过一年的时间好后就去学习
我可以给你指头路
一年时间你只要能做到
你能向我一样自律
一年时间你得不起
一年时间
你能让这一万块钱
增哪个百分之五六十问题不大吧
但你得做到
你得做到
你老想的赚钱是不行
你就会会钱
但你想的提升自己
这个钱很容易转
当然我没说做大钱
我也不会做大钱
但他增加小钱还是容易的
传来小钱还是很容易的
我们我之所以头路钱
不是说把他不是把自己丢到钱而已
各位你们去看
我其实一直在给大家讲
讲钱的事
但是你看我在抖音上
在货吗
你看我败客吗
这些东西都是亲人意语中钱的
对吧
但为什么没做呢
我为什么还要讲钱
我觉得郭德康有一句话说得特别好
就是你验证一个
验证一个
象征演员水平的一个比较好的方法是什么样的
商业啊
对吧商业有人愿意滑钱
来轻你的
这个像是说明你的像是可以的
对吧
你免费一帮人来听
那爱是一个不行
是吧
所以
所以我跟大家说
就是
我们要谈认钱
你看好多五龄大侠
不用不好劣
这个钱的问题
钱通常来不需要考虑
但是我们不行
我们要考虑钱
所以我们要给大家讲一些
让我们得以生存的钱通常来来
这样的话
你就不用把时间
把经历放在钱上了
你就可以有更多的时间去提升自己
好多人问啊
比如说做抖音做突破内的好做吗
这曲约谁做
是吧
这曲约谁做感谢空坤
所以你问我
你们我说胡子哥
做抖音做突破内的好做吗
那你要是问我的话
我肯定说好做呀
因为我好做呀
但是你一号不好做
我不知道吧
突破内的东西曲约有什么呢
曲约你能不能给别人带来讲
曲约你的东西有没有深度
曲约你的东西能给别人带来什么深度
所以你在问这个问题的时候
如果把我担心去的话
我认为很好做
我觉得我瞬间分分钟
我就可以起个好做突破内的
那种没有问题的
但是你以我不知道啊
对吧
你的你的支持处理能力啊
可不可以做呢
这个我就不知道的
所以我不能告诉你
做抖音突破内的好好的做
我只能告诉你我
我做突破内的好好的做
怎么做
我都一眼是了
我经常做呀
马斯克说2012年2022年有经过危机
怎么看
我觉得
我觉得这样的
他说的这件事情
我大概率会发生
我很想想
你欠那么多钱
你欠那么多在乌
那么多在乌
那么多钱
你现在要
要加稀
你肯定要加稀
感谢问题
那你加稀的股市肯定要
要要要影响
有受受到一些影响啊
对吧
所以这种事情
大概率会发生
就算没有发生
他其实经济也是受到影响的
对吧
但是和我们又没有关系呢
我们会受到多大的影响呢
对吧
来咱们记得看这
讲开始的和大聊吧
聊一些我最近的一些东西
还是老婆
还是老婆就
都知道我现在其实就是在一边
和家聊天
然后一边分享我对这有谁的理解
这里也可能更过地点
最近可能更过地点
来我先说几个事
我也不知道我原来讲的哪
我好像上次讲的韩述了
所以这次的话呢
我想
接着讲
然后还要需要帮让我讲
那个怎么去做笔记
怎么去写点什么
我以后给他演示一下
然后今天的话呢
咱们是这样的
想到哪就说哪了
聊到哪就说哪
然后我也可以跟大家分享一下
我先
我先说什么的过程
可以跟大家讲一下
我是什么写书的
我是怎么拍短视频的
说实话
我根本就不太关注
怎么拍短视频这件事情
虽然我短视频可以拍得很好
如果我愿意的话
我可以把短视频
前两天有个小伙子
特别有意思
在下面交我
说你知道你为什么没流量吗
因为你讲那个东西
听多了以后感觉全是廢话
我是根本你在交一个300万分次的人
怎么获得流量吗
我可以给大家吃的你过
我就我想获得流量很容易的
我知道怎么获得流量
但是我觉得很没意思
特别没意思
我觉得特别没意思
我觉得
我如果是为了获得流量
我不是被流量绑架了吗
对吧
我应该是我玩独音
应该是我玩独音
而不是独音吧
我呀
所以其实我越来越感受到
比如说我又说拍了视频这一样
其实就是找个地方写点什么
然后我做个直播
就是和朋友们聊回去
接着我们去讲
接着和大家分享
来我说的支持吧
来
老伙计刀招怎么回事了
所以我也就不妃话
也不解释
那么现在的话
我现在把整个书的内容
我成够了一边
成够完了以后的话
我现在把东西
所有东西就变成三个感觉
我来跟大家说一些三个感觉是什么
就是
首先第一个部分语读是什么
我来给大家解释
语读是什么东西
语读其实在语读的两个东西
就当晚拿过一本书的时候
我在去语读的时候
很简单啊
说起来好像很简单啊
而且确实很简单
但是我希望不能笑吧
在里面能读到有一种的东西
主要也
我要给你讲的东西
今天给你讲的东西
不会让你顿护
但是有很多东西
我讲的东西
你讲完以后你去照的座
我后面会给大家分享很多
你照的座
就可以做得很好的事情
我来跟大家分享一下我怎么去读
我在说一边我怎么去语读
在说一边
通常来说的话我语读是这两个人
哎呀
我觉得很多很多小伙伴
都已经
可以
会背了
我们很多小伙伴
都已经会背了
就是我是怎么语读呢
通常我在语读一本书的时候
是这样的
我会准备两关比
一关银光比
一关千笔
然后当我
当我去看一本书的时候
比如说
当我
找到一本书的时候
我不读亚当四名的
读大胃里家图
第八是九岸
当我读
这本书的时候
我会读
我会从上旺下的去读他
那读的时候的话
我会
我不是一个
这个字
一个字是一行一行的读
一行一行的读
大概的话呢
营部司航
比如说
四名是5点
学派的人
并建议学派的基本的
7点
但马上的三次
同时的大胃里家图
却进一步发展的干学派的领袖人物
为家图证明了
抽象徒律方法
购劲经理求理论的可能性
他将经济研究的饭丑
追
从上旺下的读
从上旺下读
然后要读的时候的话呢
他有一些生存的细节
你就知道了解这个人是谁
然后了解
货币的问题
然后收益的演合
第一次理论
你让你看的观众
一追到
有些关键词
你要改得话出来
就是我在读的时候
我只会话什么呢
听我说话
真录了所难受
没没事
没事
我关键这样
你出去就好了
你就这样就不难受了
这哪儿呢
你在哪儿呢
为了避免你难受
我帮你
我帮你的什么
我帮你一把
拉黑不就完事了吗
对吧
你看
我就这么散解人意
从此以后你就不用难受了
你看
不要线我
我叫雷粉
然后
然后你可以发现
这种补法
找到什么呢
找到这个关键词
关键词
解释一下
就是一个坐之软
它其实真正有用的理论
就那么一样
然后在设计的东西的话
都是建立理论和理论的联机
于是各位我给大家演示一下
我怎么去
认识我来给大家看一下
来大家看一下
两种方法
一种是什么呢
一种是化
最种用最种比去化
那个关键词
然后建立关键词和关键词的联机
我来给大家找一个
我曾经化过了
有一本我曾经化的特别清楚的
给大家演示过
好的
来给大家
这个我是给大家演示过的
然后以后我得告达另外一种做法
就比进流的做法
我来给大家解释一下
我看看
我曾经给大家演示过
但是我不知道为什么那条
其实是挺好的一条视频
结果被谁呢
看
大家看看
看到了吗
你看
我不是那种
不是那种多话
看到了吗
我不会都话呢
我只是画关键的部分看的吗
然后我通常会用这个比来画
一条关键词
然后在这个位置的话
就画联机
好
这是一种方法
读书的时候的方法
那么我告诉大家
还有一种方法
还有种方法
怎么画呢
来为大家演示一下
还有种方法这么画的
还有种画的这么画的
就是
如果我看到一本书
就拿这个来给大家演示吧
咱们既然已经到这里了
我就拿这个来给演示了
既然
我看到了一本书
通常拿着
拍的
或者是什么呢
或者是用这个指都可以
指既关键词
首先首先看估值
关键点什么
估值
所以我来这个位置
就写出来估值
我来给大家演示
我是怎么读书的
然后我就会写一个估值
然后第二个文的话
就是我可以看一些PB
他主要我只搜关键词
然后是什么呢
然后是资产负债别
资产负债别
这里本就会有提取的过程
然后是什么
然后是为什么
好
注意
对不起
我再读书的时候
跟大家说两种方法
一种方法
什么呢
就是拿着我银光笔在上面画
那么一种方法
就是像我这样叫笔记留
什么叫笔记留呢
就当于读书或者听讲做的时候
记住
只记最关键的东西
比如说
他说了一句话
但只记最关键的东西
然后你只需要去换
这个和这个的之间的关系就可以了
比如说估值
那么这个位置
估值和PB之间有个关系
估值和PB之间有关系
什么意思呢
因为估值得别会有很多方法
我把它标在这儿了
那意味的是什么呢
是之一
那旁边可能还有一些方法
比如说陷阱流化
对吧
可能是PB反而
但是这个地方
我采用了PB
所以我就在这个位置
去换了个联系
那么这个方法是怎么做呢
你需要去查看资产科代表
去查看资的科代表
有很多比较
但是我查看资产科代表
然后紧接到位置什么
注意
各位
看到我画了这么一条线
它不一定多看
注意不要好看
我很早的之前
我是做思维导徒的
就是我最早就要说
都说我是做思维导徒的
我看他很多人
在讲你怎么读书的时候
用的也是思维导徒
但是我有一段时间用的
是思维导徒
但是后来我发现不合适
我就开始采用这种方法
叫BG留的方法
那么这样有一个什么好处呢
记住了
越读
真正读东西是什么读的
我来给大家解释
当我们从
当我们在经济越读的时候
不过是一本书
这本书
然后当我们去越读的时候
这个时候你要去越读的时候
你要理一解越读读的是什么
各位
你真正要越读的是
不断的两个东西
拿两个东西
一个是亮点
一个是跳的脱气
一个是跳的
脱气卖弱
一个是跳的脱气卖弱
一个是他的脱气卖弱
一个是什么东西呢
一个是这个
就是他的
heal重要的
关键快宁
好了
现在我把一个磁
单拿出来
我希望单能够理解
当我们在
重新说一遍
当我们在月度的时候
其实你在重一点在独立闸口东西
拿两个东西
一个是逻辑卖落
一个是关键概念
你读得这个
所以越读首先要学会的第一件事情是什么
是你要能区分
在这样的一篇文章里面
那些是关键概念
那些是关键信息
那些是扶住信息
你要能够分的清楚
什么是关键信息
什么是扶住信息
然后在你的大脑里面有两个东西
一个什么呢?
一个是逻辑卖落
一个是关键概念
大赏吗?
我的读书
我不知道我说到这时候大家能试一下吗
然后你真正读取的东西
也就很清楚了
为什么很清楚呢?
什么是逻辑卖落
逻辑卖落
就是作者的思考问题的方式
关键概念就是这本书的知识点
我们不是读小说
对不对
当我们读一个知识的时候
其实你在读两个东西
第一个这本书交回了你什么?
关键概念
这个作者的思考方式是什么
你在学习这个领域的思考方式
所以你真正学的是这个
因此很多读书是不会读的
根本能理解了吗?
这个是能理解的话
如果这个是能理解的话
那么好的你在学习的时候就容易多了
就特别特别容易了
我们来说一些怎么去学习关键概念
来
我们去这两个东西吧
所以我们外国就学习两个东西吧
怎么学习关键概念呢?
学习关键概念的方法是
对
一个作者
他要写本书给你
他其实翻过来调过去
再给你讲我一个概念到底是怎么用的
就一张里边
通常就一个关注点
你明白吗?
有意思吗?
就是一个作者
从头到尾
想来一样去就一个关注点
我跟九历子比如说四个换一半这本书
我这一张就在给你讲谋定效应
从头到尾在给你讲的
调了三个给你讲的那个谋定效应
然后于是你就会发现一个很神奇的现象
他在讲的过程中
他一定为了让你的语绝
他一定是语境加关键词
好
这里边
我来给你
书理一下
我不知道这个大
我稍微有点抽象
但是个别思考一下
他外面的让你的过程语绝
他一定是语境
你也可以把它体解为场景
加关键概念
到你英语
所以他为了给你解释清楚
他一定是把这个关键概念
给你放那个场景里面讲给你听
然后别人理解
有些人不太好理解
是因为你的语境都不太了解
如果你理解了通常是你理解了
他讲的那个语境
下的关键概念就理解了
那么
如果你会了之后
你要学会的意见是什么
是脱离原作子的语境
把它切换到别的语境去语续形
只是最好的学义方法注意
这个位置我要重点讲了
我不知道大家都不能理解
这是一个很重要的学义方法
而且是一个非常非常重要的学义方法
这是你才学习一个支持的
一个重要的邮集
好了
我把这个事情
重新说一遍
然后我再告诉你去这方法是什么
我相信能帮助很多人
把这个问题解脱出来
如果你写的不是小说
如果你想从一本书里去学东西
其实你只需要提出两个东西
一个是关键概念
一个是邮集卖多
所以比较好的两个方法
一个是
批注法
一个金汪米
一个签名
你也可以采用思维导圖
出学者可以用思维导圖
它能帮助你找到关键的眼
和卖落
那么我推荐大家使用这种圖
各位我推荐大家使用我这种圖
只持续关键概念
然后在关键概念和关键概念之间联系
我来告诉大家为什么只持续关键概念
来
很多人寄笔记的时候
我刚才说很认识学习的最大的误具
喜欢哪个笔一本去听课
我个人更喜欢哪爱派的进东西
哪笔一本听课的人
老师在讲的过程中
他会说通过手键盘在超级
老师在讲
他快说通过键盘在超级
超级完了以后
你会发现他有一个厚厚的笔记
他回去再去看
我告诉你最终学习方法的错误的
最终学习方法是错误的
一个笔交好的方法是
如果你真的怕漏掉的话
花点钱
我不推荐他家的杀词
告大家花点钱
每个入音笔
你说我老师讲东西
然后我去敲敲玩回去再看
如果你只要这么做的话
我告诉你花点钱
键盘的手机
买个容量稍微大点的
努力就可以了
你在上课的时候
只有一个作用
上课的时候只有一件事情
就是当航
想办法
把老师给你讲东西
去明白
然后我告诉你
这个时候
职计关键概念
职计关键概念是个什么国际呢
你要想记关键概念
你就必须找到老师讲的
那个关键概念是什么
他基于你对整个上下文的理解
同时你要基于理解的基础上
你才可能抽去关键概念
然后当你在这个线和线之间
建立联系的时候好了
这堂老师讲的课
关键概念和卖落究理解明白了
走走的话
你通过键盘去敲
你最后所有的东西
只是把老师的东西通过你的指家
遗到了电脑上
你并没有完成学习的过程
明白了吗
所以如果你记不住
路于比或者是手机路
只须关键概念化罗记
好了
这是我说的第一个部分
然后关键概念是我来了
现在你要学习关键概念
我刚才又说了一遍
关键概念的逻辑是只学里边的
重点的部分
看开的场景和关键词之间的联系
然后你知道该怎么学吗
注意这里边有关键点了
你知道后面该怎么学吗
好
你已经找到关键概念了
我告诉你第一件事情是什么
我们不是卖路于比
我可能没关系
你用手机路于也可以啊
记住啊
一个比较重要的方法是什么
主题约独
如果一个词一个老实讲的关键概念
或者看一本书讲的关键概念
我来给你解释一下
当它解释一下
关键概念的时候
你要明白这个世界上
可不知只有它才解讲这个关键概念
能力了吗
所以你要主题约独
我给大家举了意思
我不知某人
这个没有批评的意思
没有什么意思
但是我想跟大家说一下这个逻辑
最近有基本书
出来了
我看好
消出帮特别高
很多人都在买
那我觉得这么多人买的
我也看一眼吧
然后我就看了眼
然后我看完这个书的时候
我很头疼
我是这儿书还能出版吗
这种书都能出版吗
这种书是典型的
三手支持
然后给你煮成了一本
我不解释
我不说书明了
你们就感受一下
真的有的时候
这个书一看
我这不是二三手支持
煮成了一本
然后我发现这本书还去热消吧
然后很多人还在下面去
说这本书多好
很多人是不读书的
我告诉大家一个逻辑什么
我告诉你真正逻辑什么
记住
一个支持
如果他非常重要的话
一定不会只有在一个人去卸
所以当你看到一个关键干净的时候
你要做的第一件事情是主题约度
就是同时买好几本书
那明白吗
同时买好几本书
然后我告诉大家
这个时候有些工具
真的可以帮你
因此
电子版的
有些书是电子版的书
是有非常非常非常大的好处的
我们就不说名字
你肯定有电子读书了
你比如说听到啊
比如说微信啊
比如说微信读书啊
比如说比如说
得到啊
都有
你肯定有这样的电子版的书
比如说听到
然后你会发现
你去找到这个关键干净的时候
你只需要在上面搜索就可以了
于是你会发现可以搜到
一堆和这个关键干净相关的支持
和这个关键干净相关的支持
然后在你一夜了
这个内容的
有境
逻辑框架
和关键干净之后
这个时候
不要忘下毒
既然是想关键干净的
今天有很多小部分
说胡子哥
我是应该把一本书好好读下去
还是同时读好多本书
你是明确的没名外
学习的目的什么
学习的目的是为了学习支持
你独一本书还是多很多本书
那是刑事
千万不要为了刑事
千万不要把自己均匀于刑事
能明白我意思吗
好了
然后你就找到另外一个
讲这个关键干净的
我给大家9例子
比如说
我听到过一个支持
这个支持名字叫什么呢
这个支持是比较复利性
效仰可以吧
这个支持的名字叫复利性
你是不是看见本书的修过的复利性
但是注意哦
别玩
理解完了以后
把他的逻辑和关键子看完了以后
你在
你在一个毒树软件
这种毒树软件很多
我自己有的时候
比如说像我跟人用微信毒树
或者得到都可以
他咱们
有一堆像复利性
看明白他
没太棒了
就在这个时候
坏肃切换
找到其中
别人也讲这个复利效仰的
打开
然后看他
这个人是怎么讲复利效仰的
注意
当这个人讲的时候
你就会发现
他跟你切换到
另外一个场景和余镜
于是你会发现
有一个很奇妙的事情发生了
你看到一个关键时代
这个余镜成立
在那个余镜成立
当你多看几个余镜的时候
你就能举一反散
于是你就会发现
一个概念
他可以在这个余镜
在这个余镜
然后他就会已经发你的事号
已经发你的想像
你再学东西
就不是死记了
你会发现
就是关键时家里的余镜
还没办法吗
当你有关键时家里的余镜的时候
可以了
你常试着写一段
你用你的余镜和场景
加上这个关键时来解释
刚才你学到那个复利效仰
这样你就不会军余
这个人说法
很那个就说吧
然后你就很奇妙的发现
你学会了
看懂吗
这叫写点什么
我看很多人很神奇
看一本书
从头看到为
你看啥呢
你的目标是看完这个书
还是被得去到这个知识
如果你是被得去到那个知识
用我这个方法是很好使的
明白吧
没完
我告诉你
再有一个方法
所有的又一个神奇的事情
来我关键点拿出来
来这个方法拿出来
记住
当你学习这个东西的时候
要学会住岂队
住岂队
然后在住岂队里面
你会发现出现了
余镜
加关键时
然后你会发现
余镜
加关键时
然后是自己的余镜
关键时
看明白吗
这个时候你来写点什么
然后我在告诉你个方法
当你这个方法使用多的时候
你就能很清理的变别
斗音里哪个
哪个人的知识
真正是自己的知识
哪些人是超的
这个
没完
我再给你讲一个很有意思的方法
你们再去考虑考虑一下
刚才我说什么
当你看了多少个人的余镜的时候
现在余镜一堆老师
对吧
然后你再和人沟通
然后我来跟你讲第二
什么叫余镜场景
例子
你不知道什么叫余镜
不需要成长景
例子
可以
你看这个人是跟着什么例子
那个人跟着什么例子
看他十个把的例子
你是不是就理解了
感谢小家
好
这是我说的第一个问题
第一个问题
我说的第一个问题
然后我来跟你讲第二个
我来跟你讲第二个
我告诉你
第二个更高级一些
但是可能有点难度
既然这个知识如此重要
那你就不应该把更多的关注点
放在二手知识和三手知识上
努力找到这个知识是谁创建的
找到这个知识最找的创建人
能明白我意思吗
对吧
能理有意思吗
比如说
当我学习比较优势的时候
那我肯定很想人员
我要查到大卫理家图
当我看到
看不见的手的时候
我要找到亚当司命
对吧
我可能要去找到他
然后认真去读
这个人从头到尾的东西
追
一个关键概念出来的时候
这个人一定会去验证他
所有的东西概念出来的时候
他是开山的祖
他一定是要验证
这个模型是有效的
于是在说明这个模型的时候
他一定有当时的论文
这个时候你去读他的论文
你去读他的文章
他提出这个观点时的那个邏輯结构
你在学习什么
你在学习这个人的思考方式
哇
太棒
那你叫我意思吗
除了主题的读以后
你要素缘各位
还好就做素了
我们叫与缘素缘
当你素缘的时候
你就能找到这本书这个关键概念
提出来的那个邮计
因为太后舒服所有人
当时是没有的
当时是没有这个概念的
是他提出来的
太后舒服别人
找到他最早的那个认文和概念
比如说
马尔沙斯线紧
我告诉你
读马尔沙斯线紧最好的方法是什么
是他最早的那个认文
最早的那个版本
然后你在读的时候
哇
他原来是这么认证的
看明白了吗
一个大家